foreign
here we go
[Music]
I don't want to work I just wanna bang
on this muggle did you ask me here for
any specific reason uh yes I did
once a year they bring in a little cart
and they give away free pretzels
it's really not a big deal
to some people it is productivity is
important but how can I be productive if
I have this one little thing in my brain
that I cannot get out and that one
little thing is a soft pretzel
so I'm just gonna have my soft pretzel I
got to work and I'm gonna be super
productive look out for me
oh
sh hi please tell me you have a sweet
pretzel left we do oh my God and we have
18 different toppings we have sweet
glaze cinnamon sugar chocolate white
chocolate fudge M M's caramel dip mint
chip chocolate chip marshmallows nuts
toffee nuts coconut peanut butter
drizzle Oreos sprinkles cotton candy
bits and powdered sugar
is there any way that you could do all
all of them the works you got it all
right thank you
Thunder Mifflin this is Pam
he's uh on a sales call
no message
bye Jan
Mission comes out too
[Music]
zero okay well it can't be zero Kim I
entered the sale and I hit enter and I
said
I'm pretty sure I timesed it right you
met your commission cap last week so
from here until the end of the fiscal
year your commission will be zero what
are you talking about we we have a
commission cap it's a new corporate
policy
is this job really about the money for
you Jim I mean isn't this where you fell
in love a commission cap takes away my
incentive to sell so you realize I now
have no reason to work right well since
I have no incentive to sell I've cleaned
my car organized my desk and taken a
multivitamin so
what now
okay now I've tried everything did you
prank Dwight
well you like that yeah it's not as fun
if I'm not blowing off work I love you
but I'm kind of busy so I need you to
figure this one out on your own
[Music]
um
oh nice wasting time here we go hey back
off it's solitaire
Hey kid
you're looking for work talk to me how
far can you reach those lovely long arms
here's
yeah but no
how long can you hold that pretty little
breath of yours
good
hey Jim
are you distracting these people we're
working
can you at least try to look busy
[Music]
are you going to be working down here do
you want these down here no work no work
I come in here to release frustration
well I like to swim that's good put you
on a cool place to come if you want to
come down here the door's always open
clock's broken so
here we go
yeah
espresso oh yeah gotta keep yourself
dehydrated that's rule number one okay I
love it I love it
HR have some rules against talking about
this kind of stuff
hearing aids are it's a joke
I can't do anything about anything
hey Ryan could you start consolidating
all our Rolodex information into Outlook
uh it doesn't seem like there's much of
a point if the company is going under
but if the company doesn't go under then
we'll finally have all our contacts in
one program companies probably going
under it'll go either way seems like
it's leaning one way maybe we should
just wait and find out definitely okay
so should we wait to find out before we
start doing all this stuff yeah might as
well do it now
hey Ryan how's it going
here's the thing
um I've tried like five different ways
in my head and oh got one
um I'm such a perfectionist that I'd
kind of rather not do it at all than do
a crappy version simple data entry
though so there's really only one way to
do it sounds like you have a really
specific vision for it do you want to
maybe just take a walk at it you know
what what I think I know the problem
great I think you seem distracted yep
that is the problem
playing that game again second life is
not a game
it is a multi-user virtual environment
it doesn't have points or scores it
doesn't have winners or losers or
there's losers I signed up for second
life about a year ago
back then my life was so great that I
literally wanted a second one in my
second life I was also a paper salesman
and I was also named White
absolutely everything was the same
except I could fly
you've got no taste Stanley Hudson oh I
do what are you guys talking about some
actress whether she's hot who's the
gallon question Hilary Swank ah Hilary
Swank
she looks like a monster it does she is
a beautiful movie star so maybe we
should just go to work she is an amazing
actress that's not the question she's
not hot yep thank you okay okay why
don't we just put this to a vote and
then we'll be done with it I'm not
voting no one cares who thinks that
Hillary Swank is hot razor him
okay and who thinks that Hillary Swank
is not hot
five
thank you accounting department
so what do we do now each side will have
three minutes to prepare opening
arguments top
Bobby Swank is attractive the debate is
whether she's hot what difference does
it make attractive hot beautiful we're
talking about the same thing here huge
difference a painting can be beautiful
but I don't want to bang a painting okay
TMI see that
the obvious symmetry of the face
it's a natural appeal of the scientific
standard of cornophilia features that
are composite average of many features
yes she's attractive but
it's not hot Kevin would you like to do
the change from last week yes yes why
him don't lie get the windows
previously on Varsity Blues okay Billy
Bob got a head injury but coach made him
play so then Lance he gets sacked and
he's out for the year
hello
not everyone approves of movie Monday
I won't say who
I don't approve I don't
hello
let's go after that time now
let's go let's go
let's go
hi Graham hope you brought the milk
badge how would a movie increase
productivity Michael how on Earth would
it do that
people work faster after
magically
no
they have to to make up for the time
they lost watching the movie oh my God
Kevin I am still on hold you're supposed
to get the answer from Michael and come
back up is a no work Zone please respect
delay
yeah respect delay
when I discovered YouTube I didn't work
for five days I did nothing I viewed
Cookie Monster sings Chocolate Rain
about a thousand
when I discovered YouTube I didn't work
for five days I did nothing I viewed
Cookie Monster sings Chocolate Rain
about a thousand times